hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast the paradigm shifts in
clinical microbiology i'm kristina jo of
lab roots and i'll be your moderator for
today's event we're delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
roche diagnostics as a global leader in
health care gross Diagnostics offers a
broad portfolio of tools that help care
healthcare providers in early busy I
projects that help healthcare providers
in the early detection group to
prevention diagnosis and treatment of
diseases in molecular diagnostics Roche
is driven by a vision of working with
laboratories like yours to improve the
medical value you offer in microbiology
virology women's health and genomics and
oncology rose continues to meet unmet
needs through investment in research
innovation and scientific excellence
with a role in supporting your important
role in improving patients lives for
more information go to www us
Diagnostics Roche com here's how the
presentation works we want to hear from
you questions comments and even answers
can be submitted via the green Q&A
button at the lower left of your screen
will try to get everyone but if not we
will make sure to follow up with you by
e-mail you can enlarge the slide window
by clicking on the screen icon in the
lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you can't hear or see this
presentation properly let us know by
clicking on the support button at the
top right where the Q&A button and the
lower left this is an educational
webinars and thus offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on a CD button located
in the bottom left hand corner of your
web page and follow the process of
obtaining your credit I would now like
to introduce today's speaker dr. Steven
cages dr. caigas is currently these
scientists
affairs manager within the medical and
scientific affairs organization he is
responsible for interfacing with
clinicians and key opinion leaders to
assist and commercialization of products
within the roche molecular diagnostics
portfolio steven has expertise and donor
screening using both the koloff's s201
platform as well as the kobus six
thousand eight hundred and eight
thousand eight hundred he is also the
leader JC is also the lead for the
microbiology assays for molecular MSA
Steven which works for at roche for five
years in several capacities he worked
directly with customers as part of a
global customer support by handling
complaints as well as assisting
customers on site he has also worked as
part of the operations investigation
unit to perform quality investigations
related to all kids and contaminants max
manufactured at rms steven has a
bachelor's degree in biotechnology from
Rutgers University and a PhD in
microbiology and molecular genetics from
the university of medicine and dentistry
of new jersey i would like to now
introduce dr. steven cages perfect hate
it hi Christina thank you very much for
that nice introduction and I really want
to thank lab roots for putting on this
webinar I think I'm the last speaker of
the day so if you made it this far
congratulations and I'm hoping that
you'll really enjoy my top so my talk
today is titled MDR OS and the
smarticles technology I wanted to start
the talk today with a quote and I
thought that this was a very good one to
use it was from the World Economic Forum
in 2013 and it says that humanity has
always been under constant threat from
the infectious disease robley we are
getting better at monitoring signs of
health-related crisis and are learning
each other there are far fewer deaths
from pandemics today then the century
ago and we live in a bacterial world
where we will never be able to stay
ahead of the mutation curve a test of
our resilience is helpful
behind the curve we allow ourselves to
fall I put that was really apropos and
it was good for this talk so the way
that the talk is up for today it's going
to be broken down into three basic parts
the first is going to be a little bit of
background on md r OS or multi
drug-resistant organisms the second part
is going to be a current technology
overview of microbiology as it stands
now and then the final section is going
to be on smarticles the new technology
um from roche so I thought that I'd
start with a little bit of a story and
this story was presented on a couple of
different media but the story is of a 19
year old from the Seattle area who
actually got into a train accident that
cost him his right leg but that seems to
be that seemed to be only the beginning
of his of his battle because he then had
to battle several antibiotic resistant
infections and the quote that he came
out with was my life consists of
watchful waiting and praying that the
infection like some awful type of cancer
does not return this type of a comment
has actually been I've heard this for
quite a few patients throughout the time
that I've been working on em dRose
specifically mrs a and we have a speaker
advocate who often works with roche
named janine thomas and she also had a
very difficult experience with both mrs
a and a different c diff infection which
we're not going to touch on today but um
this is something very similar to what
she says she often has to worry and
changed her lifestyle significantly to
deal with the fact that she has
methicillin resistance that aureus
infections and she wants to make sure
that she doesn't get any more infections
another quote oh this didn't just didn't
come up properly but there is the wh 0
antimicrobial resistance report so the
WHL published its own report and um the
their quote was that it the problem is
so serious that it threatens the
achievements of modern medicine that is
the problem of antimicrobial resistance
at the thought of
highly resistant bacteria of multiple
drugs so let's talk a little bit about
healthcare associated infections in what
we mean by this there are approximately
six million healthcare associated
infections or a che eyes per year in the
US Europe and Japan and with that about
so greater than seventy percent of those
hii causing bacteria are drug resistant
to at least one drug and in a general
sense these are some of the more common
that you'll wind up that could fall into
this category of drug-resistant a che is
including methicillin-resistant Staph
aureus are mrs a bank of my own
resistant resistant enterococcus I or BR
e and carbapenem-resistant
Enterobacteriaceae or cre I wanted to
throw a little bit of a timeline up and
give and give a little bit more
background on the idea of multi-drug
resistant organisms and a little bit of
recent history what you can see on the
top left the that is the cover sheet
from that wh 0 report I referred to
earlier and it says that governments
around the world are devoting efforts to
a problem so serious that it Britain's
the achievements of modern medicine a
post-antibiotic era far from being an
apocalyptic fantasy is a very real
possibility for the 21st century in
other words all of the work that was
done throughout the 20th century to
develop antibiotics we may be in a
post-antibiotic era with the ability of
organisms to become multidrug-resistant
over time and to all of the antibiotics
that we currently have in our arsenal in
2013 the United States Center for
Disease Control and Prevention the CDC
sent out an urgent threat warning that
there emerging infection emerging
infectious agents are resistant to all
known antibiotics that that they exist
right now and to combat this problem the
Obama administration mean 2014 started
the process of trying to get increased
funding
for antibiotic resistance and they
started a task force called combat
antibiotic resistant resistant bacteria
or carb they announced several prizes
and developed a strategy to combat
antibiotic resistant bacteria in 20 in
fiscal year 2016 the administration
asked for 1.2 billion dollars which is a
at least double what they received in
2015 to try and increase the awareness
and testing and development of new
antibiotics however they received only 1
billion of that 1.2 billion that they
asked for and for 2017 for fiscal year
twenty seventeen they again asked for a
budget of 1.1 billion dollars so they're
continually trying to increase the
amount of money that's dedicated to this
particular situation because of the
seriousness of the threat in 2015 the UK
is also looking to obviously this is a
worldwide problem so the UK was looking
to develop some more information around
it and they put up a two billion dollar
innovation fund by supported by David
Cameron by the by the Prime Minister to
try and talk about how ways that the UK
could increase the testing the picture
that you see at the bottom left is an
article from the International Business
Times and it's an article speaking
specifically about public on and
resistant enterobacteriaceae at UCLA
this is a big problem a couple of years
back where dawanda scopes were not able
to be cleaned properly and actually they
were transferring antibiotic resistant
bacteria from one patient to the next
after this the scopes were actually
cleaned in between bethey they weren't
technically on sterile so they were able
to pass in the particular area of the
scope that was very difficult to clean
they were able to pass these bacteria
from one patient to the next as they
were used so this was a big issue and
this brought a lot of attention to the
idea of antibiotic-resistant bacteria
so what is what is the threat of
antibiotic resistance look like for the
future so in 2014 there was a report
done by the wh 0 the antimicrobial
review on antimicrobial resistance it's
for the AMR report and they did some
estimates for the for the for the future
and they they looked at what what it
would look like if we didn't do anything
to take control of resistance and they
know that currently resistance is
already responsible drug-resistant
infections are already responsible for
half a million deaths globally each year
but what they said is that they expect
that to rise to 10 million by the year
2050 and have a cost of over 100
trillion dollars lost output if you
don't do things to try and control it
out we're going to talk a little bit
more about this idea of the pipeline of
new drugs or the lack of pipeline
currently um but one thing to note in
this particular picture and we'll come
back to this idea in in couple of slides
is that you can see that the 10 million
people that are estimated to be dying in
of antimicrobial resistant infections
would exceed that of cancer which would
be at 8.2 so that just puts it into
perspective what it would look like in
35 years so again this idea of the we
called it's called the discovery void
that we haven't discovered a new class
of antibiotics since 1987 and the World
Economic Forum estimates that it costs
about it costs Europe about 2 billion
dollars a year to bite into boss
productivity because of
antibiotic-resistant bacteria and
Americans pay about 21 billion dollars a
year to try and combat this issue so
obviously it's not just a health issue
but it's also an economic issue what it
costs both you as a citizen but also the
healthcare system in a general sense to
try and fight these organs
there are a couple of interesting areas
to talk about with respect to multi
drug-resistant organisms and the global
burden thereof there was an article
published that said that there were
several studies done and if you look at
the incidents of the use of antibiotics
overall that the use is actually going
up which will contribute to more
antibiotic resistant bacteria so in 2012
there if they did a study in India where
antibiotics do not require a
prescription the pharmacy sales of the
drugs increased six times between 2005
and 2010 and they found that a study in
China revealed that ninety eight percent
of patients in a children's hospital
were given antibiotics for a common cold
which we know is viral and therefore
antibiotics wouldn't be effective for
that use but constantly prescribing them
can lead to more antibiotic resistant
bacteria in a place like a hospital
which is especially prone to something
like that in 2014 there was a Princeton
study that noted that between 2000 2010
consumption of antibiotic drugs
increased thirty-six percent with most
of those coming from Brazil Russia India
China and South Africa but a related
problem is also the fact that there are
not many there are not as many
infectious disease doctors as there used
to be that are available for to combat
this kind of a problem what you can see
here is that the number of applicants
for vacancy for the u.s. medical
residences and fellowships that
infectious disease doctors are actually
only 0.8 so we're below replacement
level for infectious disease doctors and
what you can find is that the reason for
this is that infectious disease doctors
were the lowest paid among 25 medical
professions examined in a compensation
report in 2013 and they also spend they
also had the second-lowest application
rate because of the fact that they have
long hours and relatively low pay and a
second issue that's that is obviously
related is the fact that microbiology
journals for a relatively small field so
the number of journals that publish on
microbiology is relatively small and
this similar study also found that there
are five times more cancer publications
then there are complications on
microbiology so essentially you can see
where the publications are going that's
what's driving the science and therefore
were what I wind up with a bit of a lack
of information both for the mdro is
general and the doctors to be able to
treat them so in this AMR review what
they did is they at the end of one of
the sections of the review they said
okay what are five initial steps that we
can do to increase to start the process
of reducing and microbial resistance and
what they found is that within what they
decided on is fine by these five steps
the first is to increase early science
funding to tackle antimicrobial
resistance the second is make existing
drugs to go further so what they're
trying to do is take the the drugs that
we currently have that we know are
working and try and basically lengthen
their lifespan so that the bacteria
don't become resistant to them so
quickly and then we can actually use
them for a little bit longer and by
doing that hopefully we can bridge the
gap between the current drugs and any
future drugs which ties in nicely with
number three which is support support
the development and use of relevant
diagnostic technologies they said if we
had the right Diagnostics more patients
would receive the right antibiotic to
treat their infection but fewer
antibiotics would be prescribed
unnecessarily so it's basically treat
the patient with the right drug at the
right time number four would be invest
in the people who will solve the problem
again the infectious disease doctors and
researchers helped discover new
antibiotics and and help stop the spread
of bacteria that are we there and number
five would be modernized the way
surveillance of drug resistance is
dawning globally um it's important that
we are able to actually monitor what
we're doing and what the drug resistance
bacteria field looks like out there
we want to know what how many bacteria
are resistant and what the percentage is
in a particular hospital or a healthcare
facility so that's also important that
we are able to track the problem and
look at it as time goes forward so the
key role for any dro Diagnostics would
be to track resistant bacteria and
prevent their spread so essentially what
we want to do is find them quickly track
them through time and prevent their
spread from one patient to the next with
that you want to also be able to guide
their guide therapy for for patients so
what that would look like is we want to
be able to quickly rule in an effective
therapy which may be able to increase
and improve the use of today's
antibiotics so instead of trying to use
some chocolate approach or just
prescribe the next antibiotic on the
list we would want to target the
particular bacteria with the antibiotic
that we know what so if we look at the
current world of microbiology as it
stands what we can see is that there are
a lot of different segments of the
microbiology continuum so the in in each
of these areas you can see on the top
there talks about the the type of
testing that can be done and there's an
example in the center circle and then a
little bit more about it at the bottom
so in the prevention the world they're
screening such as mrs a nasal stream to
keep part of the infection control
process screening tests we use to
evaluate in patients when they either
when they walk in the door or before a
particular type of procedure to
determine whether or not there's carrier
or something like mrs a and with that we
can either decolonize them or we can
isolate them more quickly therefore
reduce the spread then there's single
diagnostic procedures which are where
you're where you have a suspected
pathogen and then you are able to detect
just for that single pathogen then you
can have a panel which are Sam on
bacteria that often have similar
symptoms and you can test the whole wide
range of those so exam
would be gastro panel where you could
test 10 different bacteria that could be
gastropod that could be gastro
intestinal bacteria and try and
determine which one of those it is then
there's bacterial identification such as
a gram of grand positive or a negative
and that diagnostic procedure is for
identification of an unknown pathogen so
it's usually at the very beginning of
the process but one final thing you have
to do is after you identify the bacteria
generally you want to do what's called a
st or antimicrobial susceptibility
testing so that you can determine which
which treatment is going to be most
effective for the patient however we're
going to use this slide it for the next
couple of minutes to talk about some
different things however what you can
see here is this is a from a paper from
nature review we can conceive that the
treatment processes and the workflow can
be very complex for for processing
samples for bacteria or bacterial
pathogens the first is that you often
have a wide series of samples so samples
our samples can be from many different
areas including buh blood body fluid
urine or even via roma feces and those
samples are that are normally sterile
you would want to culture those on a
rich medium and that can take a bit of
time so samples that are contaminated
with colonizing flora or often can
present a challenge when you're trying
to pick out the normal for from any
infectious floral but many types of
Culture Media are also used for all of
these different for these different
different types of samples that you can
collect so these are often referred to
as selective media so the media that
you're looking to grow something on will
either enhance the growth of the thing
that you're looking for or suppress the
growth of things that you aren't looking
for on that can also take a couple more
days so if you start on a rich media you
figure that for about 24 to 48 hours and
then you move on to a selective media
words if you're not sure about what that
bacteria was and I could take another
couple of days also then there's a
during growth you can check for
morphological appearance and density and
specialized knowledge for deciding
pathogenicity so likely pathogens are
then moved through a complex pathway to
determine impact and antimicrobial
susceptibility then once you find the
bacteria once you isolate the bacteria
that you are looking for through both
growth on rich media and then followed
by growth on selective media you then
have to start your identification
process and that can even start with
something as easy as morphological
appearance or density of the growth so
those are the beginnings and then the
next stage what you do is something like
a Gram stain or a multihop so these are
two general approaches and gram stain is
a chemical test I'm sure that most of
you are very familiar with it and multi
uses mass spec for a species ID before
setting up susceptibility testing so if
you're doing gram staining it takes a
couple of it's going to take some time
to do see itself and do the species
identification whereas with multi you
get the species identification very
quickly however the final stage is then
categorization of groups species is
required for the susceptibility testing
panel so susceptibility testing is often
only performed by large reference labs
as their it's a little bit more
difficult but the susceptibility are the
susceptibility testing can be done but
typing might be very difficult to
in-house or may have to go out if it's a
selected bacteria that you want to type
so the upshot of this entire slide and
what we've been talking about for the
last last little bit is that this
process takes quite a bit of time so
essentially if you're looking to do this
process over and over for all the
samples you have it can actually be a
bit of a time-consuming process and
something you may want to speed up a
little bit so some of the classic
microbiology solutions that are familiar
are
both chromogenic media which we know is
inexpensive and it has decreased time to
result in culture but its use primarily
for hii screening urinary tract
infection mrs a then there are the rapid
tests they come into a variety of
formats then there's blood culture
bottles in which you're directly
detecting from blood and the file our
panels on the agents for ID and ast and
again it can be nine you or automated
and they can be ready to use for
collections of media for ID so these are
a little bit more on the on the advanced
side in terms of their ability to do
multiple tests elements but if we look
at the clinical diagnostic approaches
this is one that we'll talk about a
little bit more on this is a what you're
going to wind up doing for something
like an Mrs a is growing it on rich
media then growing then doing some ram
singh and then you could also grow it in
selective media which would be
enrichment bra which has a high
concentration of sodium chloride and
what you can see in the middle that pink
plate is chromogenic media so we grow it
on chroma genic media the sample would
would grow pink and other things would
grow either light or wouldn't grow at
all the final system that you could use
so traditional culture if you were to
use the traditional culture route take
about three days to do do the sample to
look up a sample the third use you were
to use chroma genic culture this might
be a little bit faster and it might only
take you about two minutes one of the
benefits of using a molecular test is
that it can give you an answer as to
whether or not a sample for instance for
mrs a is resistant in about four hours
so this is a significant reduction in
the amount of time that is going to take
to get you that results to help it and
if we look here again we're going to
talk about laboratory identification
there the traditional culture methods
the chroma genic culture the chromogenic
media and molecular identification all
again for this example would be for
positive identification of
si staff and what we know about this if
we look at the difference between the
performance of pcr versus culture oh
this was supposed to come up a bit
differently but I'm sorry there there
was a study / performed in 2009 where
there were 250 qpcr positive
quantitative PCR positive and 250
negative samples were tested by genome
and to chroma genic media to fill both
direct and enrichment culture and there
were 186 cultural positives for mrs a
and what you can see by both direct and
enriched culture this is for both of
those chromogenic types of media upon us
for chrome agar and one is called mrs
and select is that the specificity is
quite high with these but the
sensitivity hover somewhere in the
eighty to ninety percent range and
that's that could be that could be
problematic and what what the what
several studies have shown is that past
performance has shown that pcr to be
about ninety eight point two percent
sensitive so an increase in sensitivity
of approximately twenty to ten to twenty
percent over the over these chromogenic
media and and about the same specificity
so you're not going to lose any
specificity just because you've
increased the sensitivity but currently
what our labs actually doing what does
it look like out there in the in the
testing world well if you look at the
cap survey from 2015 for mrs a what we
were able to do is break it down by
who's doing the traditional methods and
who's doing molecular testing and we can
see is that even with all of the data
that i just showed about over fifty
percent of the labs in this cap survey
we're doing traditional methods whereas
only about forty eight percent we're
doing molecular testing and we're going
to talk about why that might be a moment
so again what are some of the strengths
of using the classic microbiology
workflow what about what is the wonder
that will could be the problem with the
current solution well the strengths of
the current microbiology workflow in
terms of plates and such is that the
cost of the material is inexpensive
plates are relatively cheap they provide
phenotypic information on resistance
independent of independent of mechanism
and after subculture and they only
detect by bacteria but bacteria on a
plate can see any growth obviously but
some of the weaknesses are that it's a
long time to result we spoke about that
before how it takes time to grow up
instead cultures it's labor-intensive
with specially trained personnel
required you're going to need somebody
that knows what they're looking at when
they look at a plate it's expensive to
automate there are several systems out
there for automation but they can be
constantly and there's a low sensitivity
for most pathogen so we spoke about that
in previous slides that the sensitivity
is not the best with romo genic media
culturally the due to which weaknesses
culture based diagnostic tests have lost
some market share our to both and you
know asses and molecular diagnostics so
ultimately what would we like to have
you'd like to have a target of a product
that's inexpensive that provides a
phenotypic resistance information and
that's both highly sensitive and could
again have that increased turnaround
time so or decrease turnaround time you
know the rapid turnaround time you want
the information in the same shift you
want the results with high clinical
relevance obviously and you want them to
be you want those results to be both
easy to use and have low resource
dependencies you don't want to have to
babysit system that you're going to have
you want to be able to basically walk
away from system when we start so that's
now will we get into the idea of
smarticles in the smarticle technology
so I'm going to talk again so this is
just talking a little bit about what the
challenges for mdro Diagnostics so again
if we talk about those culture based
tests they're at labor intensive with
our time to resolve but we're we didn't
talk about are some of the drawbacks of
the net based tests and some of those
are that there are many different
resistance genes that are popping up and
sometimes it's not the same resistance
gene so those resistance genes are under
constant they're constantly changing
then there's a selective pressure of the
use of antibiotics and use of targeting
of certain genes and what you can see is
that sometimes the gene changes so
that's where that phenotypic result is
really going to help you out independent
of mechanism you would like to be able
to find a result that's going to give
you a little bit more information on
just whether the organism is resistant
or not not necessarily what genes it has
because if the gene changes or a new
mechanism comes up and you have to try
and detect a new gene the back based
test so this idea of smarticles where
does it fit in so there's obviously we
talked about the traditional and we
talked about the molecular and in the
traditional there's the culture and in
the molecular there's the proteomics and
aspect there's genomics which we can
detect DNA or RNA which is the NAT based
tests and next-generation sequencing and
then there's this new this new group
that we're looking to to display or to
talk about which is a live cell
molecular or it's a bio response it's
basically what we're trying to talk
about and the smarticle technology
enables a lot of those things that we
were looking at for the target portfolio
the target product portfolio which would
be detection alive bacteria it's a
phenotypic test and it's direct from
clinical samples so there's no sample
process and needed independent of the
type of sample that you're using so what
is a smarticle so this marta kontek
knology it's basically there are two
components to the smartphone the first
is the outside of the smarticle and it's
a specific bio particle that's
engineered so basically what happens is
there's a you can consider it almost
like a capsid that encapsulate something
on the inside but it
specific to a particular group of
bacteria or even down to the species
level so what we see at the bottom is
that the outside of the bio particle can
be changed and what happens when you
change it is you can change the
specificity of that small liberal but
you can get it from the family from the
family level for all of
enterobacteriaceae for instance or you
can go down to the genus level or even
you can get it down specifically to the
species level for instance something
like staph aureus and so that's the
outside of this smarticle and what goes
inside the smarticle what goes inside is
a synthetic DNA plasmid and inside of
this plasmid in it it encodes a reporter
gene so what we can do is we can monitor
the the accumulation of that reporter
gene and when these two pieces are put
together which I'll throw in a moment
when these two pieces are put together
basically what happens is that we
package that plasmid inside of that bio
specific particle of that pathogen
specific biological and that's what you
get that's what makes up the smaller
hole so the smarticle is the package
system in total so including the outside
which is specific to a particular
pathogen and the synthetic DNA plasmid
which is inside Tejada smarticles
actually work so what they do is again
there's the bacterial genome and the
smarticle will bind to the cell surface
specifically to only the cells that
you're looking for and for instance if
it were staph aureus and only bind to
staph aureus not staph epi not Hawaiian
eget it's there for any other types of
step only staph aureus and when the when
the bio particle binds to the cell
surface it injects that DNA and it's
able to transfer that DNA n to be into
the back into the bacterial cell and
during that time when the back when the
DNA is transferred into the bacterial
cell the DNA is transcribed and the
reporter gene encodes for an enzyme
which the reporter that so the enzyme
then accumulates throughout the
the matrix that it be sample is in and
over time during an incubation period
the samples are incubated and the
reporter is allowed to accumulate and
finally right at the end there is the
addition of a substrate and when the
substrate is added the reporter acts
upon the substrate and generates light
and we're able to detect that light
that's generated by the by the addition
of the substrate and the cleavage there
on the bar de smarticles cause the only
living cells to of target bacteria to
produce light so it's a true measure the
organisms response to antibiotics so
another level that you can do with each
particle technology I'm showing here is
we're going to spend a second public
this slide because this is absolutely
the crux of the entire process what
you're going to do is you're going to
add your clinical sample and you're
smarticles two years to your directly to
your clinical sample it's there's no
processing necessary and the smarticles
will only bind to your target organism
so the smarticles in this graphic are
the small D circles the target organisms
already shaded and the non-target
organisms are the background color so
the smarticles will only bind to your
target organisms that you're not bind to
the non-target organisms and one thing
you can do is you can add antibiotics to
this media that they're incubated with
and if the if the sample if the bacteria
that are present in that sample are
susceptible to that the bacteria will
not be able to grow therefore they will
not be able to produce light and if
they're not able to produce light when
the substrate is added you will not see
a signal however when the antibiotic is
added and the antibiotic is when they're
back tier are able to grow in the
presence of that antibiotic that means
the vector antibiotic resistant and when
you add the substrate again you will see
you will see light and you will get a
signal based upon that additional
substream
so there are different levels of
specificity involved in this multiple
technology so it's not just the
abilities that I've spoken about earlier
there's three levels and I actually
think there might be a fourth level but
um there's the cell surface which we
spoke about so the cell the cell surface
specificity will only happen with
organisms so again if the receptor is
not fair the organism so you can see
here on the bike and gloom receptor and
be smarter cold and black don't need up
so the lock and key are not are not
combine and therefore the smarticles
will not bind to that particular
bacterium that's level one at the cell
surface then level two is actually
inside of the cell in which we can then
target a particular promoter that would
be specific to the organism of interest
which offends another level of
specificity so we were able to target a
particular organism you're able to also
target the reporter that we're going to
use in that organism to turn on the the
reporter gene and obviously the third
level would be the formulation which you
could add a particular antibiotics to
that formulation the fourth level I
spoke about believably was this idea of
live cell vs dead so smarticles although
they will only bind to the organism of
choice one question that often comes up
is well what about dead organisms that
may be present in your in your sample
well this monocle I won't be able to the
reporter won't be able to produce light
in the presence of dead organisms
because there won't be the ability of
the organism itself to generate more to
generate more of that reporter gene so
we will be able to the reporter enzyme
but won't be able to create light at the
substrate so there's not just the cell
surface and the intracellular along with
the antibiotics there's also live
versus death so only those particular
organisms live of the particular
grouping that you're looking for whether
it be species are genius uh that that
constitute that have the particular
reporter that you're looking for and can
either be susceptible or resistant to
the antibiotic that you add to the media
that's only ones that will produce
you'll get if we go back to this idea of
mdro surveillance what the purpose is
it's again to tracklist bacterial
resistance and prevent spread and how
did this martacus technology the house
Marta chol technology does that is by
allowing the faster detection of these
bacteria and being able to get that
phenotypic result more quickly which is
exactly which is exactly what you want
you want to be able to have that result
of it um within that same shift that
you're looking for and be able to get
the right treatment to the right patient
at the right time if you look at the way
pcr currently works um when we detect
one particular gene the way assistive
works right now is basically you're only
being able to rule out a particular
therapy so for instance if you're
detecting the mecca opera on for mrs a
if you detect mackay then you're saying
oh you can't use these drugs are bad day
like this so what you're saying is don't
use this but with smarticles technology
which are able to do is actually say
what you can use so the bacteria that
would not produce light in the presence
of particular antibiotic would be able
to then give you the option of what type
of antibiotic to use to treat a
particular patient so we can see that a
sample would be carbapenem non
susceptible so that would be resistance
but you could use a different antibiotic
that go to work so that's the idea
instead of using things to rule
therapies out actually the most
important thing with something like
smarticle technology is being able to
rule therapies in
Burbage so if we go back to the idea of
all these different systems right now
that are out there for antibiotic for
resistant for drug identical bacterial
identification in antibiotic
susceptibility testing what does it look
like in terms of timing so culture can
get you your ID in a daze as well as not
stuff you have your sample and you can
alter it and get your identification um
pcr can do that plus a little bit of the
resistance markers within 20 minutes to
six hours depending on the type of QC
are but a lot of these for antimicrobial
susceptibility testing T turnaround
times can take on the order of days to
weeks to get a full susceptibility
testing done on something so the
difference with smarticle technology is
that the identification and
antimicrobial susceptibility testing can
be done in we're estimating for
approximately four hours so not only do
you do your identification of what's of
your particular pathogen of interest in
your example you can also have an
antibiotic susceptibility answer in that
time as well so to sum up about the
smarticles technology what we find is
that the it combines the best of both
worlds in terms of NAT and culture you
can do stuff you can get your you can do
your testing direct from sample you can
get same shift results and the answers
are phenotypic so the smarticles
technology is has the simplicity of
setting up an appt test with the same
speed whereas the simplicity and speed
obviously are not benefits of culture
but the phenotypic result is a big
benefit of culture and it's not
something that we could Carolee have
within that result but the smarticle
technology combines both of those into a
nice little package that we're hoping
can actually cause this paradigm shift
in clinical know provide
so with that on the I'd like to conclude
and say thank you again and I'll turn it
back over to Christina
thank you for that presentation dr.
Kagen we want to get right to your
questions and input so here's a reminder
on how to let us know what you have to
say questions cetera can be submitted
via the Q&A button at the lower left we
will try to get to all of you but if not
we will sure to be fault we should
believe you we will be sure to follow
the wealth after the broadcast okay dr.
caiga our first question is so how do
you address this concern regarding
infectious diseases physicians and the
growing awareness regarding HPV
vaccination so the this smarticles
technology wouldn't necessarily be
applicable the for HPV it's not
particularly something that we were that
was in the pipeline of what we were
looking to use the smarticles technology
for now in terms of a in terms of the
actual menu that we're looking to
develop as the assay and the system are
both currently in development I can't
necessarily disclose what the menu would
look like but suffice it to say that we
have we are working on a pretty
extensive menu for the for the
smarticles technology but currently we
don't have any information and I don't
think there is anything in development
for HPV testing Stephen does the
increase in antibiotic prescriptions in
Brazil have a link with time lapse
between consult and antibiogram
deliveries
so the the time difference between
consult and and therapy initiation could
be a reason for increased antimicrobial
resistance however studies have shown
that the the time between isolation so
what you want to do if you have somebody
who has a resistant organism is you want
to get them you want to get that
organism identified and you want to get
it treated as quickly as possible so and
I want to isolate that patient as
quickly as possible so for a particular
tests that are so putting patients
generally what they'll do is they'll
isolate the patient if they know that
they're either an Mrs a carrier or
they'll try and get the result within a
certain amount of time to try and then
triage that patient and starchy do that
in a different way in terms of the
reason for increased antibiotic
resistance in Brazil and there may be a
causal link between that amount of time
but I have to look that up a little bit
next question with respect to molecular
genetics are there plasmids or
constructs that could utilize the
smarticle technology from accounts
mechanist mekanix ah mechanistic studies
so this is actually a pretty interesting
topic in terms of the ability to use
smarticles outside of the particular way
that they have been designed up to this
point however at this point the
smarticle process in the smarticle
technology is currently only um for use
for the particular assays that we're
looking to develop and I don't think
that Rocha at this time is looking to
license that that technology or move it
forward should be able to do studies
with it perhaps when the the FDA
clearance comes for the technology there
will be different ways that researchers
could use the could use the technology
for four different types of studies and
all different all different things that
I'm sure people are already thinking
about in terms of different sample types
and in terms of different collection
systems so next question specificity of
smart viral particle is negative ninety
nine percent as checks three area what's
the sensitivity and which broche
instrument diagnosed mdro
so for this marta khals technology we
are working on a we are working on a
system that would be we're working on a
system that would be specific for the
use with the smarticles technology what
we would like to do is be able to
present that information when we have
clearance for both the assay and the
system so as of right now I can't give
you much information about the
particular system that would be running
the that would be running these
smarticles technology but I do look
forward to giving another presentation
where I can give you much more in the
way of specifics on both the assay menu
and the system itself that we're looking
to develop okay in terms of costs how
the news I have not fixed approaches can
um how the new diagnostic approaches can
provide more benefits in comparison to
culture besides the economy of time
so yes so certainly there are other
there are other benefits to the new
diagnostic approaches other than just
the economy of time certainly the time
factor is certainly the time factor is
one that would be helpful as the ability
to UM to answer the ability to answer
the question and be able to triage the
patient is certainly the time
sensitivity is also very important
however we would also want to be we
would also want to be able to increase
the sensitivity and specificity of the
systems over the traditional culture
types so one of the things about the
culture systems right now is that their
sensitivity is actually quite low and
with something like a mat or nucleic
acid based system or even this martacus
technology although I didn't send any of
that data they're much more sensitive
than traditional culture based systems
and also with the type of samples there
there's a there's often you do the
enrichment if you're going to be doing
culture and that can cause that can also
take time as well as some other things
like the requirement of a technologist
to be able to understand that culture
plate and read it and interpret it the
smarticles technology and the system
that we're looking to put forward
doesn't have any of those restrictions
on it that that would be that would also
contribute to the benefits other than
just time
sarva que Dios we have time for one more
question can you give us an idea about
the menu rose plans to develop using the
smarticle technology yeah so that's
that's the that's the million-dollar
question um the the menu in general at
the beginning will be somewhat limited
but Roche is actively pursuing ways to
increase the venue and things that we
think are most appropriate to use this
technology a little one thing that's
very important is there are a bunch of
health care providers and a bunch of
very smart people that are probably
listening to this so if you have
suggestions on what you would like
brooch to pursue or what you think would
be appropriate avenues to use the
smarticles technology we would love to
hear from you and understand what you
see in your particular healthcare
facility every day and what you think
will be the most important whether it be
a particular bacteria that you think
would be very important to to be able to
identify or a particular bacteria / drug
combination that you think would be
important so stay tuned that's the short
answer or the long answer for the long
oh well we would like to thank you again
dr. Caedus for your presentation would
you like to leave us with any final
comments
sure I'd really like to thank the
audience I appreciate you guys listening
to my talk in understanding the
smarticles technology I would also like
to thank bobrucz very much for hosting
this and for having me and again we'd
really like to hear anything you guys
have to say about the smarticles
technology and where you think it best
be used so thank you very much and I
appreciate I appreciate oh thank you dr.
Caedus and thank you again to row side
Gnostics for sponsoring today's
presentation if we weren't able to speak
to you directly today we'll be sure to
follow up with you via email thank you
for taking part well we want to thank
today's presenters as well and for
joining us here at barbara's com the
leading scientific social networking
site for more information visit us at
wwwbootysha com today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing on our
website through December 8 2016 we will
let you know when it's been posted and
we hope you pass that information on to
any colleagues who can take part in
today's broadcast see you next time
goodbye